[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation it's me
Terry ericon hello with this guy and
Flash Gordon we're going to watch now
you see me too
today I'm starting I'm doing a sing
intro do we love it or do we hate it I
personally love it but I'm biased
because I love everything you would say
so Andrew's the bestest listen guys you
got to make sure you like this video you
got to type in your comments to be nice
cool kind also don't forget to ring the
bell ring the bell thanks prepper for
helping us edit down these videos also
we call you super sexy if you get on
patreon you go to patreon.com support
the real rejects also you can sync up
with your own copy watch ni me to like
basically the whole thing with me and
Andrew okay and also Greg and John offer
exclusive highlights and watch alongs
over there on patreon so get down get
with it we call you super sexy if you
know what's up you got anything to say
before we get into this Andre I do you
know I saw in the comments of the our
first video that uh they had a missed
opportunity with the title here they
said instead of calling it now you see
me too they should have said now you
don't I tend to agree with that one now
you don't I like that I love it we're
going to get into it let's do
it tonight Lial strike is making another
sad attempt for retention by performing
what he calls an impossible feat thinks
he's able to escape dad
oh is this more backstory into uh now
see that seat there it's the best seat
in the house is strike the kind of
magician who could pull this off I don't
want you to go this is what I do going
to prove all those nay was wrong did
they recast besides I always keep
something up my
sleeve okay how many seconds 300
300 maybe a few
less cuz I think this is Mark ruffo's
character the kid right but I thought
Elias kotas was the the dad and the
first one must have
recast whoa
3003 304 I would have been worried after
200 it's interesting in the first film
Isa Fisher she almost actually drowned
in that that one water that's crazy I
didn't know
[Music]
that a little kid's a good actor people
see the horsemen as Noble Robin hoods or
are they common thieves depends on your
point of view here's what you know they
robbed a bank in Paris from a stage in
Las Vegas here's our recap they fleed an
insurance magnet of hundreds of millions
of dollars and disappeared from a roof
in New York M cocaine yay here's what
you don't know they left one man behind
fra holding the bag me
me when you emerge I will be there
because mark my words you will get
what's coming to you how is he able to
record this in jail instead of a shank
he got a
camera
welcome Daniel Atlas is that like a well
I asked to see the face behind all of
this you've asked many questions and
registered many complaints huh we've
been living and hiding you feel it is
you who should be leading the horsemen
not Dylan if that is what you desire
stay the course we have a new mission
for the horsemen Dylan has a plan and
we'll gather you together soon that
spooky
North Carolina Florida still
infiltrating the FBI it's about the
horsemen there's chatter going on about
the horsemen and something happening
with OCTA the giant software I know what
OCTA is might be Daniel Atlas maybe mer
mckin emails cell phones any transcripts
pigeons magicians work with pigeons oh
that's true they do this pigeon right
here there's Daniel Atlas same pigeon on
a sailboat with a guy that looks just
like Meritt mckin it's did you
sing a new
song sees right through him yeah he's
like he clearly he watched the first
movie yeah you don't know me but my
first year in the academy you gave a
talk oh snap you talked about a moral
compass about how you believed in yours
immutably and I thought to myself that
guy I want to be that guy and now a
pigeon you should see him when he's
angry she she's great the problem is
when you're two people people at the
same time one of them is bound to trip
the other and when that happens I will
be there do not yeah he's really on to
him huh that is an interesting position
to like follow that throughout the film
like now knowing the Twist and seeing
how he's able to balance right who are
you what are you doing in my actually
fny how did you get into
my I love her Lizzy kapan I actually
just I'm rewatching Smallville so she
was in two episodes in seasons 1 and two
and she was also in Hot Tub Time Machine
many of I made myself in the
neighborhood and now I'm
here oh no no no I recognize you you did
that bgrade geek magic thing didn't you
you pulled a hat out of the rabbit a hat
out of the rabbit that's right no it was
actually kind of disgusting do that
trick so if you wouldn't mind crawling
out from under my couch
and Tada now I'm sitting over here huh
you passed your audition what is it that
you want well I wanted to meet you I
want to be a part of the eye like you
and Meritt and Jack I know that Jack is
alive what is this Cher hitch
yeah I'm so sorry that Henley left you
oh God sorry that's actually a little
better believe she was pregnant in real
life at the time during this movie yeah
here's what's going to happen uh you're
going to stay here and stop talking and
I'm going to make a phone call and in
about 5 minutes some people are
I had a feeling that was Shake shacky
yet this movie makes me want it the
momentum of the car do the work for you
mhm this last one I call the star I
thought it was all in the hips wrong
movie now you want to see a thing of
beauty I do indeed here you go and bingo
bango
bongo that's good not bad when it comes
to hypnotism the student has almost
become the master I like confidence you
have the better teachers you know you're
right you're right your teacher
definitely doesn't know what he's doing
by the way was this your card yesterday
fact it was is that a physical effect
that looked awesome I was like did he
legit learn card tricks for this movie I
would I mean I mean that is not easy to
learn Danny what's up man stare at the
palm of your hand and as your eyes
change Focus you will begin to notice
everything cuz I'm not hypnotized it's
not working please don't become
him do you think Lizzy followed him
somebody broke into my apartment some
amateur who knew everything about me
everything about Henley leaving
everything about us that's her oh or she
already knew where they were what is she
doing here I'm the new Horseman I'm the
girl
Horseman well Lulu's been on the
Underground scene for the last decade
and I I think she has some real talent
and I'd like to try her on stage to
balance out the duo to balance out the
doess the issue is that we have been
rehearsing for months what it is you're
going to keep working until we work as a
single organism I know I've heard you
say that I think what you're referring
to is us you know not you I'm getting my
orders directly from the eye you guys
are this this amazing tightnit family
unit I'm a we are anything but a family
like wrong franchise octa's hosting the
launch of the NextGen cell phon they'll
siphon their users information to the
black market meaning OCTA selling
privacy to up their
profit the eyes decided to expose fored
our mission is to hijack the show
rehearsal is over guys so we're in the
sequel does that mean the group is going
to go through some kind of a turmoil we
shall hope for pure entertainment and
drama purposes can't have you texting
tweeting recording or eating security
Memo from case himself we're all good
I'm heading to the control room all
right thanks J Atlas go no don't I what
what's your problem ooh that looks
good what oh that was cool what shut up
that was awesome you see me now you
don't you understand sake just case uh
John from legal just need your signature
for release thank you so much thank you
so much that is such a normal thing
where people in that position of power
just don't even oh nice don't even look
at what they're signing right buddy look
I got a job to do I have a job to do too
so listen I'm going to need some backup
in security my name
is thank you very much I'm not this gu
not calm down please hey what's going on
this is so elaborate I love it I'm not
him say here Evans metal facility Mark D
stew hold on seen this before in my
amazing love that cannot trust anybody
in this city anymore
you I want to call my hey what's going
on I want to call my boss in this jacket
hey hey make your phone call that's your
right that's my right
what the
hell I'd love this is giving me like
ocean 11
Vibes yeah I could see that so quick but
it's fun like that too yeah I can take
over from here Clark says you're on
break who's Clark who's Clark it's funny
imagine if I told Roger
that who the hell is Roger is he going
to do his hypnotist trick on him you
make me have to go to Brian why are you
I'll go straight through
[Music]
oh oh god oh she was able to do the
beheading in uh in Jesse eisenberg's
room so she's good at doing that stuff
by the flow of blood which is fully
fixable in the snack by focusing and
following which is why you're focusing
on my command the voice in your head
this is that voice oh W cool I felt like
I was almost hypnotized just listening
to
it the
light this is like Lizzy kaplan's
character in party down which is I've
never seen such a good show I
quit all the people are like I just saw
bone
oh oh gnarly you imagine if you're a
customer you saw that or a gas good
morning octoly good morning
octoly I like his accent playing that
OCTA 8 is pure magic but the truth is
that's just one of those things I say I
mean something else when in fact here to
fill you in on some of my fabulous slies
in hypocrisy curious what he signed too
earlier they are the world's greatest
magicians here to expose me for the
fraud I truly am oh the fraud I truly am
wow
awesome oh that's a dope intro
shut up that was so cool he's mocked
your privacy when you signed uh probably
without reading um the terms and
conditions of
Oct
what uh FBI is here oh no
B go to plan C4 hey boss I'm glad you're
here they have three plan C's and now
they're using a four so everything that
he had once considered
private have a feeling this movie is
going to be built on plot twist
that he once considered private is now
owned some other magicians trying to
upstand them the Horseman like to say
magic is about controlling perception
this is crazy we got to get everyone to
the other entrance let's go to the back
no Danny everyone get off the stage
abort does this feel like saw right now
to you a little bit yes the voice I this
is just the plan
C4 and now for the big reveal
have they met their matches there's a
fifth Horseman FBI agent
roads the FB Dylan who are you
sorry
whoa yeah baby magic Now You See Me Now
you
don't cool I want to that I was going to
say that looks fun
nice still looks fun where the hell are
we like can we get some food first
noodles look delicious why are we here
why am I freaking starving
see oh
wa wait how did that happen that's
they're in another country because they
went down a apparently we're now
surrounded by Chinese food I think where
we are right now they don't refer to it
as Chinese food it's just
called okay yeah how is that POS they
just went down a slide I believe in your
particular par the word is Magic I'm so
I'm so confused remember I told you
about the guy who screwed me out of
everything this is my twin brother Chase
oh oh okay wait did you do
this oh my goodness and you know what
they say what happens in
maau uh well I don't know the rest of it
cuz it's in Chinese uh hey thanks
guys hey thanks guys that's still like
the thought of that sliding down 20 to
30 seconds from New York gets you into
China I'm like how I wanted him to
explain like how it worked I had to some
trick cuz at first I thought maybe they
just built this within New York how does
it feel to be out of control perhaps for
the first time what do you want you're a
fool agent roads you always have been oh
you're wondering if I was behind the
Horseman's recent tobacco I'll let you
work that out for yourself and I'm not
playing de it's not my game agent Road
it's yours do you think my cocaine had
something to do with it like he hired
the new magician I don't know it is very
interesting because you mentioned saw
that he said this is not my game it's
yours and there's always one specific
person that has a game and now we know
it's might be mostly Dylan's just tell
me how you did it delivery guy came to
your door about a month ago
Pizza okay d33 75 not even
close oh oh he hypnotized him oh he
didn't know his brother could do it so
what he did my little W mate is he uh
downloaded all your private information
oh damn wow the hypnotist was hypnotized
all right so sorry yeah you should be
don't ever accuse me of betraying us
again okay he was hypnotized that's I
mean it's really not his I mean he's
probably just mostly apologizing for his
crazy brother I know but again that's
not his fault
yeah who is this that's the most amazing
room I've seen in a
minute what expel what I did not know
that he was in this well in as much as a
magician who pulls a rabbit from a hat
is working with that rabbit he knows a
thing about magic I believe he does yeah
you're Walter Ma you died a year ago yes
an idea I got from you Mr wer so weird
to see him all there like this you all
want an audience I just want to be and
100% off the grid yeah because the grid
is for actual human
beings would you like to know my friends
just how I got you here we know how you
did it no you don't serious strobe was a
combo Boral Beach as well as I said stop
you may not be having fun but I am H in
your heightened state of agitation you
saw the simplest cues black tube roof
and your mind's filled in the rest the
tube you meant to go down was 20 ft to
your right okay but how does that
explain how they got to
China contained letters pulsing the word
sleep
oh and then they drove to China yeah
it's it's a it's a quick ride from New
York
to oh my God I love this that's really
creepy that's like reminds me of The
Hangover like the app yeah okay so it
was instantaneous for us yes okay that
makes that makes more sense why are we
here then well to start with the the man
you stole from last year turns out I had
invested quite a lot of money in some of
his companies so M cocaine Owen and I
were like the Beatles and like them we
had a dream could we create actual magic
Owen wanted it for himself so he
humiliated Me by exposing my private
files to the board of directors you take
a picture of him while he was
sleeping he goes around to taking credit
for a chip that's not just a key to one
computer but every computer system on
the planet oh that which includes your
targets a crew led by South African
gangster so how your team gets by
security that's up to you you just need
to inspect it and steal it that's it
come on this is perfect for you yeah
we're stealing for Harry Potter guess
now it's starting to really feel like
Oceans 11 I'm not theing the thing for
you not unless Dylan tells me it's okay
really actually we'll do it we're in Mel
the old magic store in the world is here
we'll get the supplies we need and uh
we'll do it he's been so Keen to be the
leader of the group too with there's
going to be something hidden he's got an
ulterior motive I feel like for doing it
Oh you mean uh Jesse Eisenberg
yeah it's Morgan Freeman oh okay I
didn't get to finish my lobst just makes
me very grumpy okay let's cut the CRA
Lobster in ja Lobster in prison I don't
even get Lobster here you Ed the form 29
warrant to search my room you found a
connection between me and The Four
Horsemen you can take me out of here on
a 24-hour leave I've C you by the balls
when your little Vendetta ended with you
putting me in jail 18 months ago you
stopped paying attention and that's
where you lost or you can make a deal
with me and Save The Four Horsemen that
makes sense cuz his whole purpose and
being with Morgan Freeman stopping him
yeah we can't trust Walter okay the eye
has a history in maau they're the only
ones we can trust yeah but even if they
succeed for Walter do you think he's
still going to let them live plan man
don't
know whoa cool shop I love magic shops
yeah um we we need some things custom
made actually by tomorrow we're kind of
in a rush and uh you have no idea what
I'm talking about do
you what is she
doing welcome to Ian my name's Lee
notle what got you okay
look is that the ACT ctor from Green
Hornet who played KO so we need a
keplinger hold out and we also need a
roughing fluid a Sonata gimmick sleeves
tracks that's all in plastic yeah I'm
pretty sure that is KO from Green Hornet
my green wants to know why plastic uh
we're going through a very sensitive
metal detector so plastic nothing
metal you say it's just because you are
talking slowly and moving your hands
doesn't mean she can subtly understand
English so sorry he RAC
hey can I use your phone it's kind of
important
sure I don't know howse thanks even if
it's crust country that's how we've been
contacting the eye Dylan's not going to
like this not really concerned with what
Dylan likes okay I'm doing this for us
he's going rogue I want to know who he's
talking to in the eye you don't think
it's his you don't think it's his father
his father right said I have something
up my sleeve remember I mean it could be
my sources telling me your Horsemen are
in maow it's n of your business who your
s es there some old friends are you
surprised he's still able to use his FBI
badge and all that after yeah cuz he was
just I mean he was outed I would think
it would be like everything revoked and
everywhere like Dylan is wanted he's not
allowed to use his FBI bad any I agree
every girl I get close to I end up
taking their trust and then their wallet
you take their
wallet did you take his Chase as you
stare into my eyes you will find that
you want to sleep when you wake you will
beg for Merritt's forgiveness and
realize that you will never be half the
man that he
is hey you had a good teacher so very
very sorry about how pathetic your pure
Bo is hey ah dang it do you think by the
end of the film he'll get it he'll be
able to do it yeah he must question is
on who Morgan Freeman maybe I'd be lying
if I said I didn't think this road would
lead to the great wizard behind the
curtain and in theend end I might get to
see his face listen to me I broke you
out of there we're not changing the
terms now you put me there yeah because
you deserve to be there listen I did not
kill your father is he really gone 30
years and the greatest long game magic
trick ever created just to put me behind
bars I don't know what you're talking
about you're lying it was an empty
experience just like a poison you think
you're luring me into a trap you're not
my only concern is the health and
well-being of the horsemen and you're
going to leave me to them and if you
don't I promise you you're going to end
up far worse than in some cushy jail
cell somewhere I was going to say that
did look I mean he get Lobster it's a
nice jail I mean that take me to prison
if I get that if I get those AC you know
accomodations what if the horsemen don't
actually need you to save them well then
he's out of a job prediction do you
think his dad's alive or no I don't know
just that line feel like the line I
think up my sle like why did he wait so
long wanted his son to to go through a
psychotically torturous lifestyle had
his Pike he's RSVP with what looks like
a couple of members of his security
detail apparently he travels with a
different bimbo every week H I wonder
which one of us gets to play the bimbo
Woody
arson you trust your people implicitly
you will have them take care of
everything and you will wait in the car
and eyes open wide awake so glad you
could make it I trust my people
implicitly but I'm sure you'd like to
see it for yourself check the build
quality also fine ah love that okay
you'll have to remove all your metal
watches Rings excuse me for asking where
might I have seen you before no yeah
that's right they're famous the book
jacket oh thank you so much uh which
book they they've been uh so many I got
your email Dr malakis you had a query
about our ability to maintain Quantum
coherence at room temperature I did I
sent it so uh what gives actually the
grownups are having a meeting Buffy you
hold on to that shut your mouth hold my
gum every seventh grader know the second
law of Thermodynamics all ordered
systems tend toward disorder Disorder so
I'm going to ask you one more time sir
what gives I'm sold we do it's actually
topological Quantum order the emergence
of quantum effects on a macroscopic
level so that is in fact what gives that
makes
sense damn that thing really goes
off
[Music]
this is the housing oh snap 820 million
cubic miles of dapic resonance
cool oh my God I must be allergic to
something this room is hermetically
sealed I'm allergic to hermetic seals is
this part of the plant it's got to be
need to be sterile if you intend to get
any closer ah
okay any
contamination have to stay away from the
in work going on Mission Impossible
awesome it's pressured too like this is
very time sensitive situation
yeah nice searching
please that is so
brilliant
nice brilliant cool
oh
oh well
done well done well done well done that
is
sick oh my God whoa hey walk on my
[Music]
own y I want to know how they got the
camera in there
yeah
hey do that myself you just met
man this is such a a wellmade it's very
creative do you have anything I don't
know can't trust anybody they're clean
yeah do your final checks and get them
out of here oh my God I that was a lot
of tension and
suspense oh my God goodness whoa you see
in the
court oh they're still checking that it
just doesn't
end thanks pal appreciate that how many
times did they have to practice
that a
million you guys are pretty serious
about your security
huh D joh okay uh sir I think uh I think
you still have my wallet remember I uh I
gave it to you when I came in he's going
to throw it into the
[Music]
wallet
whoa this TCH everything
right Dam remember he could barely fling
it at the beginning with Haron now he's
skipping cards man so now you know that
Dave Franco has to get the hypnotizing
down at some point cuz one of them's
gotten the other down if anyone asked me
to skip rocks I'm going to be like no
we're going to learn to skip cards that
that probably was my favorite scene in
the movie yeah that was awesome God I
can't even imagine how long that took to
film excuse me have you seen these
people says her grandson spoke to their
leader you speak
man so many twists and that's why he
worked for the
FBI
[Music]
whoa the the back room magic shop is way
cooler I was going to say this place is
massive
awesome the audience thought he just oh
okay oh that's got to be crazy for him
of his dad's stuff and the case the
safe I believe that's the prototype for
the one your father had
memories your father used to come here
when you were young the safe was made
from cheap metal now it bow you all
always had something up his sleeve
unless he reached the limit of his
capabilities no it didn't now I really
feel like he's still alive my
grandmother has something you might want
because they said it bowed but that
didn't he had several of Le
made well if there's one thing we've
learned from so far in these two films
nothing is as it seems his dad's
watch wait if that's that's his dad's
watch that he was wearing when he said
look at our watches together all
right has he escaped H oh man 24-hour
plan turned into oh man I didn't know he
was a magician too I just thought he
exposed them if you really sit around
studying those videos probably get
pretty good at it I'm assuming it was
actually not you who walked into Newberg
federal prison and walked out 30 minutes
later with thus Bradley
he used your ID oh cuz he used a
different ID that's why okay we we were
wondering about that oh still I would
have thought they would have had like
wanted pictures of his
face but it's prison and they're like
probably don't want a lot of T in there
this is the last place we think he's
going to visit I
guess hey I blew it I'm sorry okay I'm
here to help now okay we definitely
don't need your help no I'm in charge
I'm meeting somebody from the eye yeah
now they agreed to meet meet me to
exchange this computer chip for our life
backs Atlas give me a stick you're not
our leader anymore okay if you really
want to help us you would leave sure
that's the last we'll see of him or that
just could be part of their plan to be a
ruse so much fun know you'd be scurrying
away from me at the lab just to bring it
to me here I don't trust him and yours
obviously is ego stay the course great
changes are in store trust that your
unique talents will not come recognized
oh that was him who telling you oh
Meritt downloaded all the files but how
do you think we were able to find him
what you actually put your phone on was
a by wve siphon pad once again science
beats magic
M ooh you really think I'm going to walk
away from you don't give me it all right
don't ever question me again Beat
It Go To
Hell oh not the fishy
whoa y'all better watch out he's in the
FBI okay so he redeemed himself
there that was pretty
good oh oh
damn
whoa that was good that was really
good
h notice he's got the color green Tara I
do he's hulking it
slightly oh little cute
bunny whoa see later
dude oh and Jesse Eisenberg said he's
not a
[Music]
magician
yes
[Music]
waa a now he's caught chill watch the
pretty birdie
fly oh no doesn't work on me not even as
a
distraction ow good job nice to be
involved so they're working together I
just saw Dylan um something happened
here what happened atas I I don't know I
don't know you got to rescue him now
sacrificed himself for you this is what
they
want oh that's Li strik safe okay we got
to follow that truck they must have
Dylan we don't know how much time did
they say that uh that he's related to
Mich Kane no oh I was thinking maybe he
was his son or something oh you I share
a very deep connection with my father
like you I'll stop at nothing to avenge
any wrongs done to him Oh you mean Harry
Potter yeah oh yeah that is Michael
Kane's son yeah I believe mine's still
alive get him up okay so they did no no
it's not his father I think he he
invested money in that company right
that and so they were close oh okay I
don't think it's his dad
though
so this my
cocaine when my father died your
insurance company denied my mother
claims she died known who your mother
was once you made yourself known it
became very personal my son yeah the
sociopath oh okay okay there there you
go your Horsemen have it you will turn
it and them over to us
no like any good leader he sacrificed
himself MH now they got to rescue him I
want you to know that when you're gone
we're not going to stop we're going to
destroy everything you believe in
starting with the Horseman and ending
with the eye now then I I still think
the ey is his father is Mark ruffalo's
father oh just cuz that line trick up a
trick up his sleeve
yeah this is to bring back some
childhood memories oh
God he's going to discover what the
trick up his sleeve is when he's in that
case oh boy and maybe him having that
card does he have 300 seconds to get out
of there when it's from in the water you
shall SA
oh my goodness that would be so scary
that was a long
fall you got to stop breathe look around
use that card he has still still has a
[Music]
card where is the trick up the sleeve oh
the watch to see if his dad's what
chicken you something I'm must
leave yes
okay yes all right oh and it turns on
[Music]
amazing oh cool it's like a blueprint
for how to escape
yeah come on hulky boy Bo you can do it
no Mark
what you did it yeah right okay good
there' still be so much pressure and
swim back up that' be terrible I wish I
could dredge from the muck of my soul
one Speck of remorse but I can't they
stole my money is he with Morgan Freeman
where are the horsemen there need to be
a do are all too powerful to keep them
out of the Limelight for long if they
don't make themselves known you will
find yourself in in a very similar
position it's always the central theme
in these two films about
[Music]
revenge who that they jess Jessie yeah I
mean he did save him earlier from
Walter CPR y'all come on now oh
okay
okay thanks for pulling me out seriously
you guys something's not right what's
wrong
what it's fake what what what there's a
quote um a magician's greatest power in
his empty Fist and the Very idea that he
could convince the world that he is in
fact carrying with him a secret it's
line shrink he has to be the a what does
a stick do the stick can un encode
anything it can open up a back door into
any computer we not only make him think
that we have it but that we're going to
use it to expose and destroy him him
yeah use his own ego against him heck
yeah of us but we also need supplies
right and resources and probably more
than five people go to the magic shop
really think you don't have help oh she
speaks English of
course the fool is the most powerful
card are you part of the eye yes you've
each doubted our existence if we indeed
were watching but now we have resources
and help so who's in I'm in yeah I'm in
yay it's going to be the greatest magic
trick ever yeah we were tricked I was
exposed and brought back from the dead
so we thought that we'd do the same
thing to the person who did it to us get
my father my father we too will bring
someone back from the dead this card can
hack into any system on the planet
including ours they have it why wouldn't
they use it threat is real so how do we
stay ahead of them we need to get to
London by midnight anything that says
Horsemen brags about seeing a Horseman
time and bundle them anyone who wants to
work station throughout the city so they
can meet anywhere in 60 seconds do what
I say cuz I'm also Harry
Potter
hello hey cool my name Jack
Wilder they are so damn famous yeah let
me
demonstrate
Whoa man would you mind being my
queen don't worry I promise you there's
a 50% chance we'll get her back after
the show that's better than zero tonight
I am going to make something fly using
actual magic I'm going to take a very
large vessel I'm going to make it fly
over there and land on the temp can you
handle that no keep your eye on the
queen if you have a
location it's Jack Wilder and here we go
switch she's on the left yeah where is
she I mean she's supposed to to be on
the left but but she might not be thank
you very
much uh how did he do that not not not
my girl 100% your girl but just in this
situation it's like I don't find your
trick amusing find the pattern you do
that and you'll be able to cut them off
before they get to their final trick
like this they're beating them at their
own game I love how he has like those
little British stacks of snacks always
wherever he goes
okay everybody we're getting a patn the
hell is that freeze that and zoom
in how did he survive he's dead we
watched him drown how the hell did this
happen what are we going to do about him
we going to stop him dad for the record
I never loved the safe idea easier to
say that in hindsight I'm going to try
to control the weather yeah um oh this
I'm
interested I'm not just going to make it
clear up no no no no no I'm going to
make it actually stop
oh the reverse the reverse rain
yeah
whoa yeah that would make me stop making
out with someone too if I saw that not
me make it go up yeah the reverse rain
we saw that in the magic shop awesome I
had a feeling that was going to come
back around that's so
dope s show me the lady you know what
I'm actually starting to feel kind of
bad
what you know it's unfortunate that it's
the wrong kind of
attention how what's so cute let's kill
him right I don't like that idea I'm on
my way I'll see you there Lula stand by
all right I don't know just go and
see cool where you headed Tower Blendon
tower bridge near Tower Bridge bro if
there's any chance of us ever having a
relationship there's not I know where
you going I have a feeling that he was
expecting him to come for some reason I
don't know why yeah meet me at the r
point now was that an act of God no that
was an act of me and of strob lights and
Rain machines cuz you're going to need
to know all of that for the final
cool you're going to have to wait to
find out I know I'm sorry I'm sorry I
love you
all
[Applause]
whoa
what that is so you got to say
regardless of what you think of these
films the magic is always entertaining
so good where the hell are the horsemen
well you can chase them all you want
you're just going to wind up holding
your own
Tails or you can let them come to you
chase their own Tails like lobster tails
what the hell happened my goddamn
brother happen don't worry about it we
just got to get to the destination Lula
can you handle that thing I can ride it
have you asked the guys that question or
just me
[Music]
uhoh oh
no oh crap get
uhoh leave no one
behind that's the break that's guess
you'll figure it out come on
follow that's it it's very easy it's not
hard to learn how to ride a bike or
anything
ow
[Music]
ooh
nice okay those things are really
dangerous is the eye going to have to
save them one of you has something we
[Music]
require they switched the handcuffs I
couldn't they did something you make it
almost too easy I me even your hilarious
attempts to make yourselves
unpredictable just follow the same
pattern each time set up set up set up
big reveal I almost feel like they
wanted to get caught well that will be a
big reveal and it will come now start
with
her Danny give him the
[Music]
card I wonder what happened to the
original
one you should have planed this is the
both of us we this is clearly this is
planned out this is a setup right yeah
they're like I just have to say
congratulations it's real what you say
it's real what is he talking
about well done my boy is he lying that
it's real I'm so I don't I'm so lost
right now which is good is the most
expensive bottle $1.2 million and I
saved it just for this occasion that is
such a waste of money same bottle Liquor
Shack 700k you got what you wanted mean
you're letting us go what should we do
toss him out he's really a good brother
I came into the world with the wrong
family but I'm leaving with the right
one this is how I you out of
the oh it it has to be there has to be
like parachutes they have I guess we're
going to find out
yeah he's like touching him each one on
the back the brother I feel like
hypnotized he's yeah or he's do he did
something to help save
jeez what the hell no is it supposed to
taste like that is it piss it's all
setup fool yeah okay so the screen that
they were reading said that it was
real oh oh oh what this is
crazy that's awesome what what how did
they do that
Heman that was quite a trick that was
awesome I do
that made them go to a certain location
and then do that I'm s did they do that
how do they move the the plane you feel
pretty good about yourself man you
predicted it correctly the TS stroke of
midnight New Year's Eve happy New Year
oh now he's extra
exposed unbelievable we are moving now
all back up into position
set you're staying here course
H
oh oh he's got a trick up my sleeve
literally up my sleeve he has brought
himself back from the death he revealed
someone and he is our friend and he is
our leader Dylan sh get over
here good leader hello hello I like how
Jesse Eisenberg has accepted him as the
leader yeah it's good character
development these fellows here are the
ones left in the dark so let's see how
closely you are watching our show okay
remember when we were playing find the
lady yes classic switches and a few
duplicates oh that's how we switched the
driver of the truck which took us to a
duplicate hanger oh okay that makes
sense so they plan to get caught how did
we get it to
flock well we used fans and lights and
raid machines cool is this a movie trick
we needed to make sure that you would do
exactly what we needed you to do once
you did catch us my brother Chase there
we go yeah so we we said I he taught us
that it's all about blind spots yeah
surprises well the reason I thought that
was convenient Watch the watch I'm
wearing aware of where you're watching
and S
oh I knew it was going to come back he
did it we showed them everything how you
kidnapped us to steal the very thing
that is in your pocket right now
whoops what you said you could use to
adjust markets manipulate governments
these men destroy people's lives yep
tonight they are finally stepping into
into the light ah yeah
Bravo there's more inside me the
horsemen are over on
them did you really think you were
catching them Road hold it right there
do not
move are they going to start making out
she's in cahoots with them this contains
everything I'm the same man I've always
been now you're playing the long
game yep nice like I want to become a
magician the very awesome yeah but it's
still never been revealed who the eye is
I still think it's his dad but could be
totally wrong yeah I have a lot to show
you look like a picture of Morgan
Freeman I thought for a sec oh it is
what why are there pictures of Morgan
Freeman in there well we did see Morgan
Freeman walk by when he was a kid when
his dad was going down in the safe your
father and I were Partners yeah what I
was a highe realist he was the dreamy
eyed idealist oh my goodness public ey
did go him only thing we didn't count on
was
it going so wrong oh why didn't you ever
say anything shame guilt regret oh okay
that makes sense too look I put you in
jail man what why didn't you say
something then well you know I was going
to but then you were so quick to show
your personal motivations that it
spoiled the trick for me and those
Lobster Tales were good but when you
came back to myself you had let go of
your 30e vettor against me for your
Horsemen ah you became the leader and I
knew it was my job to see to it that he
became the magician he was born to be
the Octor show was a setup to expose him
to the public jeez you were right about
the horsemen they needed to learn to
work together like a single organism
wow what this guy was in on it too now I
know why you look so familiar You're The
Horseman aren't you oh my God like we
did that whole yeah that whole thing for
you it was entertaining for us it's okay
you know the best tricks work on many
levels and the deepest one for me at
least is this moment right here I'm
sorry Dyan
even if he looks different than the
first film yeah it's your game now you
play it however you see fit oh he's the
eye now or so the head of the eye okay
so um well obviously we have a few
questions good luck to you all pay no
attention to the curtain what's behind
the curtain it's his father I'm just I
don't know doubt he
survived I got when you emerge I will be
there cuz one thing I believe in is an
eye for an ey for an
ie wow very cool
wow cool good job John Chu Good twist oh
Ed Solomon that oh Bo is yakin that's
the director of Remember the Titans um
Whoa by the way if you are listening to
this on Apple or spotifi if you can
leave us a review we'd really appreciate
it it really does help us rate it rate
it rate it use those magic fingers of
yours to leave a review please uh I
really enjoyed it uh as the first film I
mean the thing I appre and the music by
Brian Tyler awesome as well uh the thing
I appreciated the most um obviously you
know the magic is going to entertain me
the most of course but you know on a
deeper level uh I liked you know Mark
ruffalo's storyline just you know like
becoming the leader and then just the
the theme of like Revenge I mean that's
that that was a theme in the first film
as well as this one too and then like
trying to become a leader as well and
then you had uh Jesse eisenberg's
character you know he wanted to be the
leader as well and like what's best for
the group and the dynamic of the group
so those were the things I appreciated
the most I did definitely miss Isa
Fischer not being in this film because I
really enjoyed her so much in the first
having said that I really did like
Lizzie Kaplan a lot she's she's such a
great actress um I and obviously I was
so happy to get to see the wizard
himself Harry Potter in this film Daniel
R he was great in this as well I love
seeing again the pine of affection of
approval from his father I thought that
was a nice little again there was some
really good twists uh oh oh okay I
thought we had I thought we had another
little magic trick up up their sleeves
here for another scene but um uh I have
more to say but what did you think of
the film uh number one it said executive
producer or producer David freaking
Copperfield do y'all remember him he's
magician and it came up and I'm like oh
my gosh see that so David Copperfield is
been helping them with all of these
tricks in here which makes complete
sense the the stunts and the tricks in
this movie were fire like I mean insane
I mean I know they had a bunch in the
first one but I feel like this one
really really delivered and kept me on
my toes uh which is great and I also
think that um like you said there
there's a lot of these characters that
are pining after like someone's approval
which is why they're in the Limelight
and part of the horsemen right but we
saw it with um Jesse and with Mark
Ruffalo too at the same time thinking
that like he might eventually get to
meet his dad but it turns up to kind of
be his enemy like Morgan Freeman was is
sort of the father figure that Mark may
have been pining after but is was
actually an enemy the whole time but
pushing him in the direction that he
wanted him to go without him being able
to see it which is the only way that
Morgan Freeman would have been able to
get them into that position and I think
it's awesome that we discover that he's
basically the eye and handing it over to
them which is like awesome I I think it
was well done but I again in my mind I
still think that was a complete redcon
from the first film like in my in my
opinion when they made the first film
again this is just my opinion I don't
think they had an idea like okay when we
have this reveal of Mark ruffalo's
character and that Morgan Freeman is the
guy that's trying to you know stop The
Magicians and expose them
he's going to eventually be the eye and
I I don't think that's again just my
opinion if they did then damn that was a
Twist Beyond a Twist that I could have
really never seen I really do feel it
was a redcon that but again it was done
in a way that was satisfactory but it
still felt like a red conon but I mean
the way they did it I was like okay I
can I can still buy it but um again I I
still liked it it was it was still a
pretty good twist uh I didn't see it
coming cuz you clearly heard 10,000
times I thought was going to be the dad
just because again that one line at the
beginning of I've got to trip uh trick
up my sleeve or whatever whatever the
line was so I really thought it was
going to be that um but then like they
kind of did give you some hints
throughout the film that it could be
Morgan Freeman the the first scene they
did was where he did the uh when they
were in the magic shop and he did Escape
I was like wait a second how was he able
to do to do that he's not a magician and
then it's like okay here's our little
hints into uh you know foreshadowing
that he could be something he that you
don't think he is yeah I agree uh which
I like I didn't really necessarily see
it coming either but I thought this
whole movie was very very enjoyable yeah
um I liked uh I liked how they explained
it like how did they get to freaking
China I'm like oh that that was cool how
they explained that yeah no for sure and
then also too when Woody harelson and
his twin uh when I said all right
there's no way that he didn't know he
was going to uh like run into him the
only reason I said that uh was because I
was wondering why the three of them are
doing like magic tricks out in public
and then he's specifically not he's just
walking and then he just runs into him
so that's why I came up with that when I
said that um but for me like even though
all the magic was was extremely
entertaining my favorite thing was that
that long gated card thing that they
were doing uh when they were in that uh
whatever that Tech Lab or whatever that
they were in just the maneuvering and
the I think you said best the creativity
in that scene it just almost even though
the camera was cutting a bit here and
there it just felt like one long
tracking shot in a way it was feel that
way but I love the sense of suspense in
in that moment it just I really felt
like oh my God at any second it could
going it kept going like every second I
thought it was going to stop it just
kept lingering but but I I enjoyed it in
a good way and those shots that I'm like
oh I don't think that that's special
effects they probably really did figure
out how to do slight of hand it could be
obviously magician in place especially
from behind in the front it could be a
special effect or they could have
learned how to do that um I don't know
probably it would be great to see a
behind the scenes of this film of all of
the films but this one specifically I
think it would be awesome as with that
scene to see what behind the scenes are
and how they got it shot and how um if
they had a bunch of stand-ins or how
they got it done would be awesome to see
and their escapes I love when they do
like with the cards coming down and then
into the rain into the rain I was like
what how do you even how do you do how
do you do that yeah I know crazy that
was really cool but wild yeah no uh good
film um and uh again we talked about
also the theme of uh Revenge also a big
theme in this film was letting go like
obviously where Mark Ruffalo had to put
aside his uh again we say put aside his
revenge even though he'd gotten the guy
Morgan Freeman even though he was not
responsible for uh his father which we
found out later but putting aside what
it uh you know his personal feelings
aside Mark ruffo's character uh with or
Dylan's character what had happened with
his father and Morgan Freeman and
setting you know being a leader because
this is all about saving his team and I
appreciate that like it's good character
moments for me personally so yeah I
liked it I also like to see in the
beginning how they they showed him uh
juggling both the FBI and being uh right
at the top almost being found out of
that he is the fifth Horseman um
obviously I'm like oh great I'm really
glad that this script didn't have it as
though everyone at the FBI was just like
we don't know he's just a regular FBI
guy cuz in crappier movies they would um
and right off the bat we see him at the
FBI going oh he's still juggling both
but that guy is already calling him out
of like I I see you and I know what
you're doing which I very much
appreciate it I think this script and
the way that all of these movies are
written and this specifically also the
way that they're shot but uh the script
is always really really smart which I uh
appreciate so much and very funny and
yeah I was going to say too I'm excited
to see what they do for the third film
because it has been announced that they
are going to make a third film Jesse
Eisenberg has said that they're going to
start going very soon yeah so uh I mean
because it seems like Mark Ruffalo is
now the the head of the eye and uh all
that so yeah that's awesome I would give
this an eight an eight eight Stars baby
say like a 7.5 or an eight out of 10
something like that it's good stuff uh
we love you guys this fun fun is a
blaster uh get to a magic shop learn
some magic we love you guys don't forget
to leave a like leave a comment do all
the you subscribe and we will see you
guys on the next one
bye